(crowd cheering and clapping)
- Hi!
- Hello!
- How fun to see you.
- Well, nice to see you too.
I was listening (indistinct).
- We have never met before.
- I have met your brother.
I ran into him.
- I know.
I've been so sorry about that.
(laughing)
- No, it was right after Idol.
He was so nice to me.
He was like really kind to me.
- How could you not be nice to her?
- Well, it's happened.
- I know
(laughing)
- Well, I know.
- Well Merry Christmas though.
So like, I want to know though.
I was asked.
Like, especially people
that love Christmas music
and singing so much.
What's your go-to at Christmas?
Like what's one of your
favorite Christmas songs?
- Truth?
- Yes.
- Rudolph.
- Do you know?
It's so funny.
I've been obsessed with Brett Eldredge's
"Rudolph the Red-Nosed Reindeer" lately.
I've listened to it more
than any other song.
- It's so happy.
But, I have a reason.
So I go by Marie.
- Yeah.
- That's my middle name.
My first name is Olive.
- Your middle name is Marie?
I just found this out just now.
I thought your first name was Marie.
- No.
Oh, my mother was Olive.
And so I'm the only girl Olive Marie.
- Oh.
- But when I was little,
I thought that Rudolph
was about me, because;
♪Olive the other reindeer. ♪
(crowd cheering and clapping)
- Oh my gosh!
- Truth.
Absolute truth.
- That might be the best
lyric misinterpretation ever.
- Right!
I know.
- I was like, are you
confused 'cause it's Rudolph.
It's Rudolph. I was like,
how did you get that?
Olive, the other reindeer?
Oh my gosh!
I thought it was a girl.I love that.
- And then did you think you were mean
'cause you used to laugh
and make fun of them like
Rudolf. That's amazing.
I love that.
Wait. Tell us about the song
you're performing for us today.
Cause I love the prayer.
The prayer is such a beautiful song.
I was listening to your rehearsal.
It was so magical and beautiful.
And it's a big song and you
sound different than how
normally I've heard you.
- It's cool.
- You're so sweet.
You know, we love music, right?
I mean, look, I wear this.
Does that mean I'm not country?
No, but the album is called "Unexpected"
and I kind of dedicate it
to everyone who changes
doing things that are expected of them.
- Yeah.
- And trying something unexpected.
And for me it was singing
legit opera classical,
and that's kind of what
this was 20 years to do it.
But I love the prayer.
Initially I'm one of the founders of
"Children's Miracle Network"
- Ya. Which is so cool.( crowd clapping)
It's such a beautiful thing.
- Ya, it's so fun.
But as I fell in love
with that song, I did it
I said, this song needs to be sung legit.
And thus it's on the album, Daniel Emmett,
who was on "America's Got
Talent" discovered again from
another show, but he is so amazing
and Placido Domingo loves him,
but he's got this wonderful
voice and I love giving new
people and young people a shot.
- Ya
(crowd clapping)
- And this guy is so cool.
- Beautiful
- He's on tour with me right now.
- That's so cool.
Well, everybody at Marie's
album is called "Unexpected."
It's out now! You got to check it out.
You can also catch her in
her symphonic Christmas tour
through December 20th.